you say while the law was being debated
if you like your plan you can keep it
you said after the law was implemented
or signed if you like your plan you
Americans believe you sir when you said
that to them over and over yeah yeah no
respect for a bait-and-switch give us
credit straight pin pins from the cattle
in Tokyo we Japan all the way we can't
but no he owes or the details her
complaints aplenty read the emails
nothing you send us any think Obama
cares falling apart by any tablet so
fast you think it's made by nature man
that a new ad campaign across the world
we got one we got one girl with you
press corps boys wanna chance inquire
could be paid for by her millions of
people are trying to accept the loss of
their plans you told them could be kept
and one thing that's baffling folks
around the planet is how of these plans
been canceled the two Broke Girls as an
I've tried and I've tried but the
efforts in vain
never has a website inflicted such pain
for our wasted time as a bailout inside
for users of healthcare.gov people who
drafted ray Ryan to keep their plan look
where that lead we didn't say plan we
said like kayak like Amazon the glaziers
pronto
my actions on the Amazon with the mayor
of Toronto can chime in G with the iPad
comment cuz why can't you come and I
don't have Google but this is your law
and now people need to help I mean you
want the things that you just knock out
game yourself
again selling hopes like selling soap
son I'll tell you why you can't make
even without a little bit of idolan
hopes like selling soap sometimes
everyone you can't make either
little live ellen hopes like selling
soaps and i'll tell you why you can't be
even one without a little bit
someone hopes like someone's Oh